[Music]
hey there Akuma fans Charlie with the
Gosser application staff today's video
we're going to talk about Cass collision
avoidance software a bunch of you that
are subscribers are going to throw up a
fit and say wait a second you've got a
million videos on Cass today's is a
little different all of my previous
videos have been focusing on
multitasking machines like the mulus the
U machine the LT complicated turning
centers where Akuma has included the
collision avoidance software as standard
but today we're going to demonstrate a
the collision avoidance system on a
regular mb4000 a horizontal a machine
that the factory has not included
collision avoidance as standard but it's
certainly available as a
bolt-on so we will talk about Cass and
let you decide whether or not it's an
investment that you'd like to have on
your Milling Center in order to protect
it from silly little mistakes first off
what is Cask collision avoidance
software
is boiled down to its nuts and bolts is
a virtual mockup of your Machining
Center that will operate one step ahead
of where you are in order to prevent you
from lumping the machine either in
manual mode or automatic mode any sort
of little mistake that would normally
cost you a a broken tool a crashed
machine a a pretty little signature in
your Vice deck all the little things
that have happened to every last one of
us in the industry at least once uh the
collision avoidance software will look
ahead see that this is about to happen
and
stop so let's show the layout basically
first and then we'll talk about how to
construct the collision avoidance
software on the left side of your screen
over here you'll see the normal p300 m
control just about everybody's seen this
at least once upper leftand corner has
the Dr with some of the uh the modal
Information Program is underneath it
next to it is the G&M codes that are
active and up above is the graphics
screen and most people on a mill they
ignore the graphic screen because all
right I know what's going on however
with a Vision avoidance equipped Machine
by touching this upper right hand corner
you can make the value of F2 change to
cast display by touching it there is the
mockup of my machine as I have defined
it and again we're going to go through
how to do that definition in just a
second but let's let's see the thing in
action first and then we'll go through
and um uh show you how to populate
things so this can be run the machine
can be run with the uh the the window up
here it's it's delightful to be able to
see what's going on especially if you've
got a lot of coolant splashing the door
you can't physically see the part I'm
just going to go ahead and go into
automatic mode and hit cycle slam and
we're going to watch my uh my part as it
goes through its process now this uh
this cast window that you see here is
probably not easy to see through your
monitor so I'm going to come over to at
my vertical function keys and I'm going
to enlarge the whole thing so that I can
see what the heck's going on you notice
that the first thing my program did was
pick up a shell Mill it decked the top
of the part that's pretty routine second
I grabbed a half inch endmill and I'm
running around the outside you notice
that the uh the graphic showed the tool
path before the tool was complete that's
part of that look ahead function even
though the graphic is showing me exactly
where the machine is now the computer is
already thinking ahead and showing me
what the material is going to look like
in several blocks that's how it's making
sure that it doesn't stop a a collision
as it happens that wouldn't do me any
good so it is physically looking ahead
and will warn me before things get out
of hand now the endmill is done walking
around the outside I do a couple of
other little things here we're going to
grab a spot drill and just uh make three
little holes again you'll notice that
the hole is occurring before the drill
goes in it's because of that look ahead
process and then my final tool I'm just
going to grab a half inch drill and just
Plunge in and out of the three holes and
then my completed part stands yeah okay
go ahead somebody give me a rough time
for not breaking the edges and yeah
we're we're just demonstrating so now
let's uh let's induce a few mistakes I'm
going to get into my program here and I
will scroll down to the end of the shell
Mill because this is the first place
where I could very easily make a
programming
error at the end of the decking process
I send the shell Mill back to the zero
point uh for whatever reason my reason
was because I wanted to induce a crash
then perhaps my clearance
uh
command at the end of every tool would
be to say g0
Z some number that's beyond the physical
travel of the machine like 90 in as you
see right here but somebody messed up
I'm not going to take responsibility but
minus 90 instead of positive 90 I've got
the negative in there that I know is a
crash however I didn't catch it let's
let the machine catch it for me hit
cycle start start the machine starts
over again let's go back to our our uh
larger depiction make sure everybody's
in super speed
mode and after this third leg the shell
Mill goes back to
0 and now the machine stops I get this
big yellow block that says hey a
collision block is detected notice that
physical uh the physical location of my
machine is still 100,000 however it's
saying oh wh whoop on this move right
here you are about to take your tool and
plunge into your
material wow all right so let's reset
that I'm going to get rid of the
um get rid of that particular
motion oh yeah Charlie you made a
mistake it's supposed to be Z Plus
90 and a little further down I want to
show you another
little oops that I can do I have defined
this tool as having about 1.3 in of
flute so now let's take
this and I'm going to overdrive that
tool I'm going to try to make a finished
pass with more flute engaged than I have
flute to spare so let's go ahead and
fire this off again and as it's running
I'll point out that um I have added
a right in the beginning of my program
I've added the word clear and draw which
is the only program difference or the
only program requirement for using Cass
the clear and draw just reset my blank
to where it
belongs uh as it's untouched okay so now
we are running the the endmill around
the outside of the
part and we're going to get to that
portion where I
overdrive now I also want to warn you
that
um my program is
utilizing that move right there as a
finish pass it is not leaving any
material on this face right so when this
thing goes down it's going to make that
first portion of the pass but now it's
telling me whoa notice I've got a red
mark on the material and a red mark on
the tool it's telling me hey I am just
about to engage material with too much
uh too much flute so let's reset this
guy I'm going to get him out of the
way got to be in manual mode get him out
of the way so convenient right well
that's not the end of the story I also
have protection from me getting all
crazy with the um the pulse
generator let's say for instance I was
just not paying any attention and I
am hand Wheeling the
machine and Bon uhoh I just jogged the
tool into the uh the work holding now
tombstones should never be machined so
as soon as this guy got within 100,000
of the
of the tombstone it said nope nope nope
nope I'm going to
stop same thing with the
vice same thing with whoa let's go the
other way same thing with the material
block oh that's a
little why there we go Boon so I can't
even jog the machine and crash it myself
it's not even giving me the permission
to do that
all right so seems pretty cool right
let's talk about how to set this thing
up there are some key pieces of this
puzzle that I have the ability to Define
through each of these um uh through the
software that's embedded and included
with the collision avoidance software
It's all under easy modeling so if I
touch this
guy those of you that uh have played
around with your control extensively you
probably have seen this easy modeling
button and if you don't have the Cass
software you'll notice that there are
only two uh fields on this left side
that you can define a tool and a blank
well now we have a whole series of
things that we can define a machining
envelope which is described as the
entire setup I have a setup right now
let's go ahead and create a machining
environment under my work setup if I
touch the collision avoidance field here
I get F1 defined jig and material by
calling this up there is my Machining
environment as I have defined it and
we're going to go through each one of
these steps as uh as we need to but I'm
also once I have set up a job and I know
this thing might be coming back I have
the ability to save that Machining
envelope and we'll just call this the
cast
test and say okay now I have saved this
Machining envelope and it will show up
in my
Machining Envelope as cast test that way
I only have to Define this this
configuration one time when this job
comes back and I'm ready to set it up
I'll simply get into my def defining jig
and material and I can read the
Machining envelope pick up the cast test
and say okay and there it is
everything's come up so I'm going to
delete and
delete all there we go now we will
transfer to cast and we'll see a blank
slate I've got nothing in there there is
a tool there we're going to go through
defining that as well but let's go into
our easy modeling and start talking
about each one of these little items
such as a blank
there's a piece of material I can create
a new piece of material simply by
touching the word
new if I have a casting that's a little
complicated I could make a rotate shape
which means I'm just going to make a
point to-point line and then rotate the
shape about it we all have done that in
our CAD systems or a basic shape such as
a square block a hole a rectangular or
cylindrical I can create any any kind of
material that's a basic primitive shape
simply by defining where is my 0.1 in X
Y and Z where's my point 2 in X Y and Z
that's showing the the square and the Z
High Point the Z low Point once I've
saved it out boom it'll look just like
so I can tell it where the uh where the
datum is going to be on this part with
the assign p 0 and once that's done I
save it because he I may use this down
the road somewhere and I can have as
many as I want in here the uh the
storage memory is
vast the next field is a fixture now
fixture is defined as a vice or a
tombstone or uh homemade fixture plate
with clamps on it whatever in the world
you want so let's just look through some
of the things that I've already defined
I have a basically a chick Vice uh the I
downloaded this chick Vice directly from
the chick website you notice it's a
little lumpy well chick wants to give me
a an STP that's very complicated and so
I used a feature called shrink wrap
which just basically encompasses
everything it is exactly what it sounds
like it throws a shrink wrap around the
outside of the part and reduces the size
of the file there is a
9,000 Triangle map maximum on the the
uh fixtures that come in and the tools
that come in so when I create stls I
want them to be as simple as possible
but let's go along and look at a few
more I have a tombstone that's saved in
here here is my this is a really cool
one this is a double um fifth axis
dovetail Vie that I uh created and
brought in anything that I own I can
store in this library and then slap them
together together here's a Kurt Vie with
the forward jaw here's the uh the moving
jaw for the Kurt so I could put those
two in and position them just right so
that um the uh uh collision avoidance
protects both the hard jaw the soft jaw
the moving everything a set tool is
described as a tool that's already
assembled it's got a holder and a tool
uh included in the graphic uh this is
great if you have a tool that uh say for
instance a shell Mill where the
relationship between the tool and the
holder never changes and so you can save
this thing as a set tool and you have it
set to the side and anytime you put it
back in you just say hey remember that
set tool put it in my magazine I have
individual tools that I've created let's
this will be a fun one let's go through
and create a tool just to see how we
would do it so I'll just say hey I want
a new tool a noncutting tool would be of
course a probe a sensor but the rotating
tool gives me a uh template of all of
the different types of tools that Akuma
knows how to create and if one does not
fall into the category I have a an item
called other where I get to Define what
the protected uh shape of the tool is
but let's just do something easy like a
oh a flat endmill or let's do a bullnose
that's a radius endmill as opposed to a
ball endmill this will be a bll nose
and by saying okay I just go through and
Define the shape of the tool I'm
currently in metric I like to to operate
this uh this in metric so let's just do
that for now my D1 shown on my compass
rows is the cutting diameter of the tool
let's call this oh let's make it a uh
12.7 let's and my shank diameter let's
also make that a
12.7 my cutting length here this is this
is important I want this to be the
actual cutting length of the tool so
that I'm protected against that overcut
that you saw in the sample so let's just
say
oh I want to convert from inch to metric
on the fly so I'm going to say that this
is a 1.2
intimes
25.4 there we go now I've got the um uh
cutting length set my overall length oh
let's say this is 3 * 25.4 hey I can do
math on the Fly and my radius let's say
this is a oh let's go A5 mm and it's a
three flu endmill as soon as I click on
okay I get a graphic representation of
the tool showing the cutting length the
shank the overall when I'm happy with it
I can call this whatever I want and say
okay and now that tool resides in my
library forever
uh I don't have to delete it I can pick
it up anytime I want and create a new
assembly with that I have the same thing
with a holder there's
a 100 mm standard I made there's a bt40
there's a sample uh these can be
downloaded direct from the manufacturer
they usually come in an STP and it's up
to you to convert them to STL however
there is also a catalog here so if I
touch the word read and pick up a
catalog here is a whole boatload of
individual type holders that are already
in your machine to help you out make it
so that you don't have to go and
download additional tools and there is
just a mess load of them depending on
what kind of machine you have cat 40 cat
50 hsk they they've got a whole bunch of
them and once they reside in your
library now all that we have left to do
is assemble them so let's do that next
I'm going to come over to my tool data
and I'm sure all of you have seen this
on your individual machine but
previously we've been doing an awful lot
of work just on the magazine info
tab hey all right there's there's our
tool you may or may not have seen
pictures like this we're going to show
you how to take care of this little
problem but our offset shows up right
here so what I need to do in order to
have collision avoidance protect me from
a tool or holder lumping in
is move over one to our tool data
tab by touching this it's showing me a
library of all the tools that I already
own not necessarily in the machine yet
but I own them they're in the shop
somewhere they might be in the machine
but these are ones I've already
constructed once you've constructed them
you don't have to repeat this they they
exist you just have to say I'm going to
attach them but we're going to go ahead
and create a new one by touching the
register tool data tab that's over F1
and now I need a tool number let's just
say 500 the tool numbers are exclusive
they cannot be repeated once I create a
tool number 500 I cannot create another
one unless I delete this guy so let's
call this the sample I have the
opportunity to stress to the machine
anything I want regarding the um the
abilities or the character istics of
this tool such as is this a large
diameter tool one where I need to keep
pockets in the magazine adjacent to this
Tool uh free and available I could just
say hey yeah this is a large diameter
tool and when I attach it it will
automatically blank off pots that are NE
adjacent to that tool also the heavy
type I could say yeah this is a heavy
tool and what that'll do is it'll slow
down the speed of the tool change arm so
that it um
it uh doesn't Wing a big heavy tool
around in our case ah this is just a
routine tool I don't need to do anything
of the
sort so next I'm going to set the tool
model when I touch that I get the
graphic window that pops up and the
first question is hey which holder are
you using so I'll simply select the
holder I'll pick up whichever one I
happen to want to use in this case let's
just say yeah okay that guy
okay by calling it up now it's showing
me a configuration of the tool holder as
well as the um the mounting point for a
tool so I could if I wanted to define a
sleeve and tell it this is like a a call
it Chu let's say that my diameter for
this tool or this holder is going to be
uh 75 * 25.4 we're still in metric mode
and my length let's make this
25.4 okay change the mounting position
to the end of the sleeve yes I do there
it is now I've got a bushing sticking
out of the thing one more I'll select
the tool let's find my test tool that
was that bullnose endmill by saying okay
it now has pointed the it's mounted the
tool but it's only protruded from my
bushing by an amount of zero here's a
really cool feature
if I already know what my stick out
value is I can touch the word Change
setting and I can give it a projection
amount let's say it's a uh 40
mm okay there it is however if I have
already defined the offset of the tool I
could change settings and touch the word
Auto set now currently the offset for
this tool is set at zero so when I touch
Auto set you're going to notice the tool
goes all the way back up to the mounting
the gauging line if I were to uh let's
just cancel out of this we'll cancel I'm
going to go ahead and set my length of
this let's add
oh 125 millim we'll call this a 125 mm
it's registered now we're going to edit
that oops wrong one it should be 500
we're going to edit that guy set the
tool models do all of the things we did
before find the sample holder Define the
sleeve by the way these sleeves can be
stored in the um uh easy modeling
Library as well but I just didn't uh
take the time to do
it times
25.4 and my length is going to
be okay there's my bushing and now when
I select my tool pick up the test tool
and I change settings now when I touch
Auto set notice that it moved the tool
for me based on that uh that value
that's in the offset and that's really a
cool thing because hey all right I know
there's a problem with my offset because
that's not what my physical tool looks
like once that's all done I will say
okay and it will store it in my tool
data library and it again I don't have
to mess with it again unless the
relationship of the tool to the end of
the uh holder changes let's just grab
this guy and say for instance that
previously there's my
offset previously I had it sticking out
e far if now it's a little further and I
change that offset let's just add oh
let's
go 10 mm
there now if I go back to my uh edit
tool data set tool properties this time
when I change settings and say Auto set
notice it moved the tool for
me saying okay now my graphic and my
tool model agree with one another one
more little thing to point out to you
I'm going to get in here and I'm going
to add out my minus 20 mm to my offset
click on the word okay I didn't update
my tool model so now when this tool is
highlighted I'll get this
little uh warning down at the bottom
tool length offset differs from sticking
out of the model hey that's kind of neat
it's a little warning that there's a
problem between my physical world and my
my dimensional world
so there we have tool
definition and I can just store these in
my magazine as they come out of the
machine I could detach hey let's get rid
of that faill now the face Mill still
exists in the um in the library but it
doesn't exist in the machine hey when I
go to stick it in let's go insert tool
pick up the face Mill say okay it's now
in pot number 10 those of you with the
Matrix magazine that's old school you
already know that uh how that
functions and we have all of our data so
now that we've done that let's go ahead
and create a machining
environment once again from my main
screen here I'm going to touch the word
work setup make sure that the collision
avoidance graphic in the upper right
hand corner is highlighted and touch the
defined jig and material now we're just
going to go through and we're going to
create the working environment that we
have there's the the the pallet that
never
changes so the machine has it by default
sitting here and what I'm going to do is
I'm going to start by adding things
let's start with adding a jig and if I
have not created it I could touch new
and Define it from A Primitive but in my
case I imported my Tombstone from the
manufacturer as an STP converted it to
an STL Lo loed it into the machine so I
can just say read and there's my
Tombstone right there clicking on okay
it now has positioned it into the
machine depending on how the
manufacturer had defined their origin
that's not how it looks no big deal
Akuma is ready for
us each one of these views has the
ability to modify the location and
orientation of the tombstone so by
touching this one I could Now set
position this is the active screen you
notice the grid is there and by touching
the turn
left hey now I'm oriented but my area in
space isn't quite right so let's specify
a position the x that looks good at zero
but the Y let's make that zero and the Z
is zero notice there's a little point
where it's going to attach it okay once
I have that in place I could save it and
now next time I won't have
to modify things in order to orient it
properly or if I were converting this to
an STP and I knew where this origin
should be I would modify the
manufacturer origin so that I just bring
it in and it's on the it's uh there on
the um on the T on the
pallet okay so I'm not going to machine
just a tombstone so I now want to add a
jig and we will read there's all the
different things we have let's go ahead
and put this um uh oh let's do
the let's do the sample Vie all right I
brought that in same problem it's got uh
it's got its orientation a little cocky
wus if we look at it it appears that all
we need to do is move it out in Z and
move it up in the air
those of you that are really astute
notice that oh wait a second the lug is
down we'll deal with that too so let's
move this guy out and we're going to
bring it out in Z by say oh let's go 125
mm give it a preview hey that looks
about right okay now let's move up in y
by about 300
yeah yeah that looks pretty good but as
I mentioned before how am I going to get
the vice handle on there with the lug
being down so now I'm going to
highlight this guy because I can use my
turn right and turn left to whoa isn't
that Nookie and it still looks like it's
a little low so let's do a specify
position and we will oh I know we'll do
a little relative move and have this guy
go up by about another oh let's go 75
mm Bon that looks pretty darn good and
now that I've got the uh the stationary
Vie on there I could easily mount it
using that same process left you know at
b90 b270 I could add more at this point
I would also add the lower jaw on there
using the same motion parameters and
just have it stationed in the the right
area once I say exit I could say
transfer to cast or save this
environment if I was going to use it and
now there we go now I'm going to move
this
around and do a little
magnification here we
go I am now protected from running into
my nice expensive Kurt Vice how Nookie
is that uh one thing I did not do which
uh is pretty much right along the same
lines let's go de jig and material I did
all of this stuff but I forgot about
adding a blank so add a blank I could
read it there's my material it's now
positioned there it's showing me my work
datm but currently the material is
buried inside the uh buried inside the
tombstone so let's move this
guy and specify position we'll go out by
oh let's go 300 millimet just because I
want to see the thing come
out to
Absolute add three oops
300 preview there it is right there and
now I could move it up put it in
position and because this is showing me
my current active g15 I could very
easily move the material so that it
lines up directly with that uh that
Compass row and now I'm
protected exit transfer to cast
obviously it's uh the material is in the
wrong spot because I didn't bother
moving it but you get the idea right so
collision avoidance this is an awesome
thing to bring into your machine uh save
gives you a lot of grief and wear and
tear plus if you have a multiple pallet
machine you can Define each collision
avoidance Machining environment for each
Tombstone and in your program you can
call up an individual uh Machining
environment with the term cast
me instead of clear and draw I will put
in Casa
CME and then the name of the Machining
envir enironment so even if you've got a
25 pallet uh fastems system every time
you bring in a tombstone you can call up
the Cass CME read the Machining
environment for that particular
Tombstone so you're not locked into one
same if you've got a standalone that
only has two pallets you want to read a
new Machining environment every time you
change pallets boom you got it done
right
there hopefully this video helps you out
in making a decision on whether or not
the Collision of voidance software would
be beneficial to your company if it is
feel free to holler at your local goser
applications or sales staff we'll give
you a quote on what it would take to put
on your machine if you'd like to see a
little bit more like And subscribe leave
a comment and uh I'll be happy to answer
any questions that I can thanks and have
a great day
[Music]